human genome project was an accident as
far as i was concerned what i really
went for was the genome sequence of the
nematode zener of dieters which i worked
on
as a result of doing a great deal of
sequencing on this little tiny worm
we learn that's to say my lab and bob
waterston's lab
to sequence rather well and so we got
incorporated into the human genome
project
we were part of it i always felt that
this was a big thing it belonged to
everybody and we should do it together
not everybody agreed with that but in
fact our consortium the international
consortium felt this very strongly
it actually goes back to jim watson as
much as anything the the philosophy
behind this the fact that it should be
international should be open and
everybody should be involved
it also fitted very well with with me
because i
through working with the nematode had
learned for myself
how important it was to share
fundamental information this is not like
an individual science project you know
like finding out how something how a
particular thing works
or finding out how to cure a disease
it's not like that it's collecting
fundamental information and making it
available
therefore it's obviously extremely
important in this area more than any
other
to be open and share everything